French president Emmanuel macron begins
a three-day state visit to the US here
Monday the French leader says he has a
strong relationship with President Trump
but admits the two disagree on some
major issues such as trade and the Iran
nuclear deal today in Paris Fox News
Sunday anchor Chris Wallace sat down
exclusively with the French president
and tonight Chris has a preview from
Paris of his interview that will run on
Fox News Sunday Chris threat we came to
the Alizee Palace the official residence
of the French president since the 19th
century to interview an annual macro on
the eve of his state visit to Washington
we discussed the major issues he and
president Trump will try to resolve but
I also asked him whether the
investigation by the special counsel and
James commis recent attacks have heard
president Trump's standing on the world
stage here in this office I'm not the
one to judge and in a certain way to
explain your people what should be your
presence or to consider is because of
these controversies or because of his
investigations your present is less
credible do you ever wonder whether he
will serve his full term I never wonder
that I work with him because both of us
are very much at the service of all
countries on both side we'll have much
more of our interview with the French
president on Fox News Sunday including
sharp differences with mr. Trump over
trade and the Iran nuclear deal but
that's it for now from the a leaves a
palace in Paris but Chris Wallace in
Paris you can see the entire interview
Sunday on Fox News Sunday check your
local listings safe travels Chris